ha we're bonded that's not how this
works welcome to the science asylum I am
Nick lucid in a previous video I talked
about how bonds don't really have energy
these bars are only here to keep this
model in one piece they're not physical
things I usually use space-filling
models which represent reality a little
better atoms are solid balls all right
so maybe it's still not the best visual
let's start with what you usually hear
in chemistry class atoms are made of
protons and neutrons and a compact
nucleus surrounded by a cloud of tiny
electrons chemistry is mostly about
electrons bonds happen when the
electrons well let's just demonstrate
with some clones two atoms could share
electrons forming a covalent bond or one
atom could steal an electron from the
other forming an ionic bond oh that's
not so bad yeah except that's a bit
idealized electrons are quantum
particles so then you all sorts of weird
things like not moving around or not
really existing anywhere in particular
so they don't really exist
oh they exist just not usually anywhere
in particular we're getting off topic
let's take a closer look at that
covalent bond in the o2 molecule you're
probably picturing some electrons
orbiting in single atoms and a few
orbiting both atoms creating the
covalent bond this isn't really accurate
it's better to imagine electrons
appearing and disappearing randomly most
of the electrons spend all of their time
on a single atom but a few of them have
an equal chance of being on either so an
ionic bond is when they spend all of
their time on the other atom no well
it's not entirely true either there's no
clear line you can draw between types of
bonds some are just more covalent and
others are just more ionic it comes down
to something we call electronegativity
which measures how well an atom can
attract electrons the scale it's usually
used was proposed by Linus Pauling in
1932 rather than use physical numbers
like bond energies a value of 4 is
assigned to fluorine the most
electronegative atom and then the rest
are just scaled relative to that upper
limit to figure out what kind of bond
two atoms will form you just subtract
their electronegativities anything
less than point four and you get a
normal covalent bond anything more than
one point seven and it's considered
ionic but weird stuff happens between
point four and one point seven the bond
is still technically covalent because
they're playing nice but one atom is
clearly holding on more than the other
and that makes him a little more
negative leaving the other guy a little
more positive which is why we call these
types of bonds polar covalent the
molecules have been polarized meaning
that even though it's neutral the charge
isn't spread evenly so wait what happens
if the difference is exactly one point
and now we see the problem with
categories the examples I chose were
obvious ones there are some not so
obvious ones barium sulfide is one point
six nine which is under one point seven
so you think it was covalent but it's
not it's considered ionic you might
think at that point that
electronegativities are just a little
bit off which is true I mean they're
only meant to be guidelines but that
whole argument ignores the bigger issue
here perfectly covalent bonds exist
perfectly ionic bonds do not all you
need for a perfectly balanced covalent
bond is a difference of zero something
easily attainable if the atoms are the
same the point for transition to polar
covalent is pretty arbitrary
technically anything above zero is a
little polarized the one-point-seven
transition to ionic bonds isn't all that
special either the electrons are just
spending twice as much time on the thief
atom to get a perfect ionic bond
you need a difference of infinity which
is impossible no seriously it's
impossible whether it's food cars school
subjects or people we seem to have
trouble understanding the world around
us without assigning characteristics to
whole groups
yes yes we all know about how everyone
assumed you were dangerous when you
crash-landed my point is physical
reality doesn't have categories it's
full of spectrums that we force
categories on two types of light phases
of matter or even types of bonds but a
bond is just an attraction that keeps
atoms nearby each other just like these
magnets or the earth and the moon
however we categorize that the universe
is going to laugh at us so if category
has ever gotten you into trouble please
share in the comments also thanks for
liking sharing and subscribing and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy
my whole life is a lie
good thing you're only a day old then